ma soeur
bah
à
concert rock jazz ou chorale saint
quentin en yvelines a fêté la musique
mardi 21 juin à la clé des champs de
plaisir le début de soirée était
consacrée aux élèves du conservatoire de
la ville
petits et grands ont pu laisser libre
cours à leur âme d'artiste
on ouvre la scène qui peut à différentes
catégories aux cultures musicales
d'année en année on varie aussi des
idées c'est laissé à chacun libre
expression je dirais de venir nous
rejoindre je découvre des nouvelles
musiques
j'aime bien voir les autres faire de la
musique découvrir c'est super fun pas et
en plus on est à l'abri cette année
aucun n'avait pas à l'extérieur avec la
pluie donc un petit cadre très agréable
à montigny le bretonneux la ville a fait
le pari de conserver l'événement en
extérieur au centre sportif pierre de
coubertin une zumba géante était
organisée pour s'échauffer en musique
avec un professeur c'était génial c'est
qu'on fait avec vous les aimerez puis on
s'éclate et ça fait du bien à l'écouté
on est venus fêter la fête de la musique
en famille
la première fête de la musique de
mademoiselle
ensemble de saxophones ou orchestre de
seine ont été installés jusqu'à minuit
les artistes de la ville ont rythmé la
soirée
on va avoir une succession de groupes
essentiellement des groupes qui émane du
conservatoire de musique mais également
des groupes locaux qui bénéficié de nos
studios de répétition une au studio
d'enregistrement
mise en place en france en 1983 la fête
de la musique continue de faire vibrer
cette année encore 120 pays l'ont
célébré